what's going on reject nation it's Greg
outlet and it's John Humphrey here so I
just got a couple of messages from
people like Comic Con and then I was
like all right go online and then
receive his anything online about this
and I just got a call from Batman and
apparently there is all this talk now I
don't know if something specific was
mentioned actually at Comic Con us a
couple of people texted me about it
while they're there here's what the
Holly reporter has to say this studio is
working on plans to usher out applix
Batman gracefully a source says
addressing the change in some shape or
form in one of the upcoming DC films so
Ben Affleck is headed to Comic Con
tomorrow to promote Justice League yes
Warner's film studio chief Toby Emmerich
health of Hollywood Reporter that is our
Batman we love him as Batman we want to
keep them in the cowl as long as we can
and that really will direct the studio
still undated and unwritten - Batman has
said he means to keep Affleck in the
role but its source with knowledge of
the situation says the studio's working
on plans to usher out that applix Batman
gracefully addressing the change in some
shape or form of one of the upcoming DC
films exactly when how that might happen
has yet to be determined but it'd be
wise to bet against applix starring in
the Batman he has already stepped away
from the directing the film and Reese's
dropping the script applica DC
entertainments Jeff John you know Ben
Affleck this is this has been the worst
part of his career he's getting worse in
workman when he was a recast as Ben
Affleck asses Ben Affleck when he was
already cast to be Batman it was already
a firestorm of people's get in an uber
agents Ben Affleck what and then watch
then he had to work his ass off the
probe he could be Batman and then he
does a great job as Batman and he was
like the savior for a year if you
imagine what it was and then he's gonna
write and direct the Batman and star in
it and he's like you know what guys
getting to back the hell off for a
second you know you guys are pretty he
got it he started understanding what
YouTube comments are a lot of demand
from comic question he's like okay I'm
not
directed Batman and then other scripts
getting can the more that keeps getting
released on Ben Affleck as the Batman it
just seems to be getting worse and worse
for the guy I don't know it's at the
point now where you know when you hear
stupid stuff like a source as usually
just some dumb rumor but it's at the
point where I'm beginning to believe
it's a possibility yeah I don't I don't
know I never know how to feel about
sources but if you do look at the
play-by-play and stuff like that
especially considering that Matt Reeves
apparently has acknowledged to you he
wants to do you know a trilogy of some
kind and then you look at this news
about like one by one Ben Affleck's
roles are coming out of this film yeah
it seems a little weird not to cast him
in that first movie but the more I look
at this the more I think about it the
more I'm like well if they're even
considering not committing to Ben
Affleck and Matt Reeves just stepped in
and wants to make a different thing for
three movies I would be psyched if they
went for old Batman and committed to
that for a while that would be cool it's
something new to do in a trilogy but you
know at least dollar reporters saying I
get it you know like I don't know if
they're going to want to do that for
three straight movies the more time goes
on the less creatively involved Ben
Affleck is yeah I feel like part of the
big part of the draw for Ben Affleck to
be Batman was not just playing him but
also being able to be creatively
involved behind the scenes and it seems
like the more time goes on the less
creatively involved he's going to be
when he was going to write and direct
the Batman that obviously seemed like a
passion project of his at the time the
more you strip away directing and
writing it's less of a passion for the
guy so even if Warner Brothers is trying
to usher him out I'm even thinking that
ethically kind of seems like he wants to
be out of this now seems like it's not
his project anymore and it's not the
dream that he used to be and you know
that they don't want to start a trilogy
off with some guy they're going to
remove partway yesterday unless they
have some kind of masterful plot to it's
where somebody takes over and it becomes
Batman Beyond yeah Hollywood Reporter
talks about he's going to turn 45 next
month
yeah and if you're going to do a trilogy
he's going to be way into its 50s by
that point by the time you get to the
second or third one he might already be
in his fifties it just seems like this
is something
athlete doesn't want to do any more like
the more interviews you hear in him the
more it seems like I just I want to get
away from the fan I want to get away
from the pressure I want to do my own
project personally I don't blame him for
that and hasn't he had a lot of like
personal life like when Aston rehab like
manias Ollie's like on and off against
what's happening with Jennifer Garner he
was in rehab I don't think now's the
time for this now I almost feel like
just for Ben Affleck's life yeah sanity
he should be so Justice League coming
out it's like okay maybe it's a good
thing the solo Batman films haven't been
done yet this way you could get a
replacement and if that's the case I
vote Jon Hamm yeah and that would be
cool it would be awesome awesome to see
that you could never have recast
Superman with Jon Hamm and so that
finally the the like the fifth Justice
League movie would all be Jon Hamm and
little mini Murphy movie that's what I
want well guys I mean what do you think
of this is this actually something that
you think is going to go down do you
think Ben Affleck will be leaving the
Batman do you want him to leave the
Bakula hyper his own sanity at this
point you should just leave this project
yeah like I don't think when it looks
like such a mess why not just when you
thought that DC you was getting
everything in over and did smoke at
Batman get any certain where you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Bell Det John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house and check out our
exclusive perks and rewards over at
patreon.com flash the real rejects told
me do you bleed apparently he does he
does